[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOANNA SMITH: Hey everybody and
welcome to today's episode
of Google+ Developers Live,
targeted sharing with
interactive purpose.
I'm Joanna Smith and I'm a
developer programs engineer
for Google+.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And I'm Silvano
Luciani and I'm also a
developer programs engineer
for Google+.
And today, what we want to
show to you is how to use
interactive posts to help your
users to bring the people that
care to your app.
JOANNA SMITH: So interactive
posts help your users prompt
their friends to take specific
actions in your app from a
Google+ post.
In addition to the standard
content links, interactive
posts introduce a prominent call
to action button that's
designed to drive actions in
your app from users in the
Google+ stream.
And so we're going to bring
those users into your
app from our own.
And this is a really powerful
tool for you because clicking
these buttons brings recipients
directly, not just
to your app, but within your app
to a specific place in the
app to perform a specific
action.
Maybe they want to listen to
a particular song that was
shared instead of just listening
to music in general.
And so Silvano, do you want to
go ahead and show us how easy
it is to do this?
SILVANO LUCIANI: Of course.
It's very easy like all the code
that you need is in our
developers doc, at
developers.googl
e.com/plus/web/s
hare/interactive.
It's easy to find.
JOANNA SMITH: So simple.
SILVANO LUCIANI: You can find
the snippets that will allow
you to load our JavaScript into
your page and then ran
the interactive post button
into your page.
But the first step is to create
a project in the Google
API console.
JOANNA SMITH: As always,
this is your step one.
Go to the API console.
And of course, we have explicit
instructions for how
to get started with this.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So we
can show this to you.
The API console is at
developers.google.com/console.
You can create a new project
using the select drop down on
the top left corner.
We will call this project Demo
GDL and this name is just for
you have to remember what
this project is about.
Let's wait a second.
So now we are in the familiar
service list and we can choose
which APIs we want to
use in this project.
So in our case for the
interactive post, what we need
is the Google+ API.
And let's click on
to activate it.
Remember that the first time
that you use a specific API
when you do this, you will see
the terms of service of the
API and you will have to accept
the terms of service
before actually start
using it.
JOANNA SMITH: And we recommend
that you actually take a few
moments to read that instead of
just clicking through like
you are probably inclined to
do because we do hold you
accountable to our
terms of service.
We try to do what's right for
our users in those and our
spam and abuse team probably
will find you.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
So now we can go to API
access and create an
OAuth 2.0 client ID.
And it's easy as clicking
on this big blue button.
At this point, product name--
I will use, again, GDL demo but
here use something that is
meaningful for you and for the
user because this is the
branding information.
So it's what will be shown to
the user in the content dialog
when they go through
the OAuth process.
So the same is with the logo.
If you have a logo,
use a compelling
logo for your product.
And also, the home page URL
where the user can check more
details about your app.
In the next window, what we do
is choose an application type
for our client ID.
In our case, it's a web app.
And what we have to do now is
add options for our site or
host name for the JavaScript
origins and the redirect URI.
Be careful with the scheme.
As always, if you're using the
HTTP select HTTP, and if
you're using both HTTP and
HTTPS, use two entries for
both schemes.
[INAUDIBLE]
is published on localhost so
what we need to do add
localhost here and we can now
create the client ID.
JOANNA SMITH: And so now that we
have our API console ready
to go and all set up, it's
really very simple to get
started with interactive post
because, once again, we
provided code snippets in our
documentation that you can
just copy directly.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
Going back to the page in the
developer docs, there is
adding the share button
to the page.
So if you click the link, you
go to the snippet that is
including our JavaScript
in your source code.
So let's copy and paste
these first.
And then the second step is
actually called copying and
pasting the code that
will render the
button in your page.
JOANNA SMITH: So while he's
copying and pasting this, I
think we should take a moment
to go over some of these
attributes, right?
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yes.
So the first one that you can
see is the class and it's
g-interactivepost.
This is telling our JavaScript
that after if has loaded, all
the element on the page with
this class needs to be
rendered as interactive post.
The styling, you can choose the
styling for the button.
We will just attach the behavior
to an element with
this class.
Content URL is the URL that
points to the object that
you're sharing.
And that URL needs to contain
the scheme of the [INAUDIBLE]
markup that is describing
the object.
So a title, a description,
an image.
And this will populate the
snippet like a standard share.
Content deep link ID is the
same but for mobile apps.
JOANNA SMITH: So let's take a
moment to talk about what deep
links are before we go on about
the actual ID for them.
Because if you haven't used deep
linking before, you might
be a little confused here.
But what deep linking does is it
allows the Google+ app on a
mobile device to direct clicks
on an interactive post into
the mobile app for your users.
So if the user has your app
installed and they click on a
deep link, they'll be taken
straight to your app, but also
within your app.
And if they don't already have
you app installed, they get
prompted to go ahead and install
it which is pretty
powerful as far as a user
experience is concerned.
But if you plan to use deep
linking in your mobile apps,
you need to create a client ID
for each of your platforms
that all live in the same
API console project.
And that's a really key
thing to remember.
They need to be in one API
console project, but you would
have one for each platform
like Android or iOS.
And then the Google+ app is
going to magically route all
of these clicks to the
appropriate place.
So if you have your deep link
set up for both Android and
iOS, we're going to figure out
where to send the user.
We're going to take it from
there and handle all that
logic for you which is
also pretty powerful.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Very good.
So and back to our parameters,
we have the client ID which
we'll replace soon with the
client ID from the project
that we just generated.
And this is because we need
to know that your app is
accessing the JavaScript.
The cookie policy, you
might know this
from the sign in button.
This is a complex parameter.
Check the docs on the website
and we will have
a GDL on this soon.
But for now, just use
single_host_origin or check
the recommendation that is
explaining to you which one is
the value that you should use.
Prefill text.
This will allow your app to
prepopulate the text in the
snippet so that you can send
the user a message that is
meaningful and compelling, and
that is actually letting them
interact with your app.
The call to action label, that's
what will appear as
text in the button, the call
to action button, which is
what you're trying to engage
external the user for.
JOANNA SMITH: And where you see
the word create here, we
actually have over 100 verbs
pre-defined and ready to go.
And so you can find that
list on documentation.
But the reason we have all of
these verbs already chosen is
because we've also
localized them.
So that, depending on your
user's location, we'll make
sure it's in the right language
for your user our of
any of our 60 supported
languages.
So that's a pretty
cool thing too.
SILVANO LUCIANI: The
call to action URL.
This is where the user will land
if they click the action
on the interactive post.
And the call to action deep link
ID is the same from the
mobile app.
So as we were telling, is this
way of actually having them go
to a specific part of the app
where they can do an action
for which their friends call
them into your app.
So now all we need to do is
get from the Google API
console the client ID that we
have just generated, copy it,
paste it back to our
source code.
And now we can see a demo
of the interactive post.
JOANNA SMITH: Before we demo,
can I [INAUDIBLE] the prefill
text and the verb?
SILVANO LUCIANI: Of course.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
So I want it to say Joanna
is the best.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Joanna
JOANNA SMITH: Because I
am, let's not argue.
And in the verb it should be to
confirm because everybody
should that I'm the best and
agree with that statement.
SILVANO LUCIANI: I do agree.
JOANNA SMITH: All right.
We're good then.
No arguments here which means
nobody's arguing.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So now if we
load the demo, this big gray
button that you can see, as we
said, this is in your control.
You can style it as you want.
We have some branding guidelines
that will tell you
what you can do and what you
can't do, but aside from that,
it's all yours.
When you click it, it's going
full screen for the content.
And now we can see the
interactive post on the page.
And as you can see, the text has
been pre-filled with what
Joanna wanted.
JOANNA SMITH: Because Silvano,
this app wants to tell the
world how cool I am.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And the call
to action is now a confirm.
And now I can tell Joanna's
[INAUDIBLE] demo, for
instance, or anyone else
to actually go--
myself, I will do
it with myself--
JOANNA SMITH: You should
all [INAUDIBLE].
SILVANO LUCIANI: Confirm that
Joanna is the best.
And in that way, they will start
using our app and check
[INAUDIBLE] the app is.
JOANNA SMITH: All right.
So the other cool thing is you
saw how Silvano is choosing
his recipients, but you as a
developer can choose some of
those recipients for your
users directly.
And what you can do is you can
actually prefill up to 10
direct recipients.
And what that means is that
those 10 people are going to
get a notification and that's a
really powerful tool to help
drive engagement for you.
And the other thing that's
really cool about this is you
can add recipients
by either Google+
ID or by email address.
So just as in a normal share
when you can send somebody a
post through email if they're
not on Google+, you can still
do that same thing as a
developer to prefill that
email address.
So let's go ahead and look at
how incredibly simple it is to
get this going.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
I have a simple PHP that is
using a new function that we
added to the Google+ API which
is people.list that will allow
you to get a list of the users
in the circle of the user
visible to your app.
And this is the code that is
showing how actually easy it
is to call this function
from the Google
API PHP client library.
We need to go list people.
Me, as you know, is the key word
to say that we want this
code for the user that
is logged in now.
Visible is to indicate that we
want the collection of user
that is visible to yourself.
And I'm also using an optional
parameter which is order by
and setting it to best.
This means that the order of
the friends will be by
interaction.
So in the first places I will
get the people with whom the
user interact the most.
JOANNA SMITH: Now the other
thing to remember here is that
we're not exposing the
user's circles.
We're just providing a flat list
of people that the user
has added to a circle that
they've shared with you
through consent dialog.
And so when we order by best,
it's not the best of this
circle or that, it's best
overall from any interaction.
But also, that entire list is
going to be a flat list for
our developers so that we can
enable our developers and
protect our users at
the same time.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
We don't expose any circles
information to the developers.
Then you can add a maximum of
10 recipients and when you
have a list of multiple
recipients, it becomes a comma
separated list of either Google+
IDs or email address.
So in this case, what I'm doing
in the PHP sample is
just taking the first 10 and
then building an array and
then it's imploding that array
to a comma separated list and
we can use it.
We need to add the parameter,
the other recipients to our
markup and just putting
the string as
value of the parameter.
So back to the new sample
which is their PHP.
As you can see now, the
recipients are pre-populated
with a list that comes
from my demo page.
And those are lists that are
in order the friends I
interact the most with.
JOANNA SMITH: So you might be
used to seeing this list come
back alphabetically but because
we used the order by
best parameter, it's ordered by
interactions, like we explained.
And so depending on what your
app is, either one of those
might be the right
choice for you.
The other thing I want to
do now that we're showed
you the demo is--
before we go, I want to take a
look back at the attributes
that we were showing
off earlier.
And I want to talk
about why some of
them look really familiar.
Things like cookie policy we've
seen in our sign in
button too.
And can we take a look
at the similarities?
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
So there is a number of
attributes that the
interactive post inherits
from the sign in.
And this is because, as you've
seen it briefly in the first
example, I had to go through
the authorized dialog.
This is because your user
needs to be signed in to
Google before they can use
an interactive post.
So if you have an app where
you have both sign in and
interactive posts, what you
want is to have the same
attributes for the sign in
because you want to replicate
the same behavior.
You want to have access
to the same scope.
You on the same type of access
online or offline whether it's
your choice.
You want to call the same call
back to perform the same
action on the app.
So for example, in PhotoHunt,
which is our end to end sample
application, in the main page,
in the landing page, we have a
sign in button, but we also
have an interactive post
button, invite your friends
that can be
used to invite friends.
So at that point, if you click
invite your friends before
signing in, we want to go
through the same call back
that will then hide the sign in
button, show your profile
image, show your profile
picture, and all the other
personalization that we
apply to the page.
Show photos from your friends,
show the list of your
friends, and so on.
So this is very important that
you do the same things and the
same flow whether you are
signing in using the signing
button or the interactive
post button.
One difference is you can do
over the air install when
you're using interactive
posts.
So that's now a packaged name
that will allow you to specify
this is my app and this is what
I want to install on your
Android device when you sign
into my application.
So if you really want that, what
you have to do is don't
show interactive posts before
the users have signed in.
JOANNA SMITH: Right.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Sign in and
then show and apply all the
interactive posts
in your page.
JOANNA SMITH: And what we
showed you when we were
explaining some of this is a
page from our documentation
that really goes over
these parameters.
But if you want to learn more or
maybe refresh some of this
because we did talk about a
lot of things in a really
quick time-frame, you can go
to our documentation at
developers.Google.com/plus
and you can read to
your heart's content.
And it will definitely
help maybe clarify
some of these things.
And of course, if you have any
questions or if you kind of
just want to talk about some of
this stuff, check out our
Google+ Developers community.
We hang out in there every day
and we also have a lot of
really amazing external
developers in that community
who they foster great
conversations.
They're bouncing ideas off
of each other and they're
discussing things that they
find with our API.
And it's a pretty powerful
place to maybe get some
questions answered or just make
some good connections.
So check it out.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Or if you'd
like to see more codes and
more samples, we are on GetApp,
GetApp.com/Google+.
You will find all our quick
steps which are the samples
that get you up in five minutes
on different languages
like Java, Python, PHP, Ruby,
Go, JavaScript, and maybe I
think I'm forgetting one.
And also we have--
JOANNA SMITH: C#?
SILVANO LUCIANI: C#.
JOANNA SMITH: C#.
SILVANO LUCIANI: That's it.
And also we have PhotoHunt which
we mentioned is our end
to end sample application that
is showing you all the
functionalities that we recently
introduced with
Google+ Sign-In.
We have a backend written in
Java that comes bundled with
the JavaScript frontend and
we also have two mobile
frontends, one Android
and one iOS.
And also we are every day on
Stack Overflow so if you have
any questions just ask your
question with the tag
Google-plus and we will reply
as soon as we can which is
usually one afternoon.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Maybe?
One hour?
JOANNA SMITH: It's usually
the same day.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Two hours?
JOANNA SMITH: And then, of
course, if you have an issue,
if you find something that's
wrong with our API, let us
know in our issue tracker.
Or if you have a really great
idea for a feature request and
if there's already one in there
that you like, you can
start and you'll get updates and
it will let me know that
it's important to
more developers.
For example, the order by best
parameter I discovered through
an issue reported in
the issue tracker.
It was broken and we fixed
that just recently.
And so, it can be a really
powerful tool for you to
communicate something to us
that's not quite right or
something that you would
really like to see.
So definitely check that out and
you can always let us know
how you're feeling about
it by talking
about it in the community.
But it can be really
powerful tool.
And that's all that we
have for you today.
So if you have any questions,
feel free to
ask them in the community.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]